sometimes I was like man these old
people when they talk about kids having
it good these days I was like man maybe
they're right maybe they don't maybe
they don't get punished enough my God I
I think I think some some kids go like
their whole life in school thinking they
just can't be punished cuz like clearly
that's what must have happened here some
father how the [__] did like these kids
commit straight up crimes and think that
like they'll just get a slap on the
wrist parents please beat
kids we need more TI to you know we need
more parents to beat their children like
I just going to say it you you need to
have you as as a kid you need to have
that innate fear of the moment when you
do something wrong that that absolute
like cold sweat passes through your body
that you know when your parents are
about to murder you and I would do that
[__] of like dropping a bowl so like we
need to bring this back I don't know if
we sto doing it you need I need to be
straight up scared of doing anything
wrong
again how that's why why I'm so well
behaved cuz every time I think about
doing something bad I can feel the glare
of my father about to murder me yeah and
that's just like the environment I was I
grew up in and like that kind of
discipline I feel just parents look I'm
not going to teach parents how to parent
such a boomer saying this like I feel
like a boomer but I feel like clearly
I'm right like people must not be
getting disciplined how does this happen
Okay for like just saying none of us
none of us are parents here I'm about to
[__] parent someone
none of us are parents here none of us
are parents but you know how we're going
to be as
parents so future children watch your
ass my kid does not get to [__] around
like that oh no find out he does
anything in school he his life is ruined
killing him AB I brought him into this
world I can easily take him out I'm
taking him out of this world what do you
mean you got to see and you are well
behaved look I think I think the big
thing is that just children just need
discipline and you know that doesn't
necessarily mean we whip out the [__]
belt or whatever that's all back in the
[__] 1960s I
can we get the belt and the
slipper we got to bring it back we got
to overcorrect throw throwing the back
scratcher in there every now and then
dude you know Choose Your Weapon that's
not what we're saying uh but we are
saying that some some kids just need to
learn that there are consequences to
actions I don't know that's what I'm
saying we need like you know Mal on the
middle when they misbehave some they had
to go to the military we should do that
you should do
that I would I would have not I would
have been very well
behaved yeah I mean like Navy Army Air
Force take your pig son oh God you're
going to one of them do do you think
okay this this going to be a weird
question do you do you think kids need
fear yeah 100% okay okay then then let
me ask what what is the difference
between fear and respect because that's
that's a very fine line you know that's
that that's a very fine line because you
can like overshoot and the kid will just
fear you and respect you but that fear
will like overshadow the respect and
then there's the fear that they will
lose your respect and that's kind of
like that's what I'm aiming for you know
I I want to instance my kids the fear
that they're going to disappoint me
right right right right not not so much
that they're going to fear that I'm
going to scary cuz I think that like if
you you could raise the kid the exact
same way and I think sometimes you could
just get a little [__] satanic little
[__] who's just who's just no matter
what you would have done I think he
would have just been absolute human God
he came out evil I think it just happens
I I mean there's like I mean I think
some some oh man I don't know there's
got to be some people who are just born
to be absolute like oh absolutely evil
you can you have to someone has to I
believe that for sure right I am I crazy
I feel like that there's you you could
like yeah I feel like there's got to be
a chance of that happening I don't know
okay well then here's the question for
you g like you are in that position
where you are very much like that with
like your dad for f the evil kid G I'm
like you have no enemies trust trust
trust you have no enemies I think I'd
get impatient I think I I wish G would G
played a long game long game he'd played
a long game what is the long
game the kid would be a little [__] and
God's like no he'll come around five
years later he comes around and it's
like oh wow he how did you do it it's
like I just waited okay you must have
had that moment right have okay tell me
if you've had this moment
your parents have told you you'll
appreciate this when you're older every
day of my life and and then there is
that one thing that you're like [__]
actually actually thank you Mom and Dad
for forcing me to learn tie because I
did appreciate that dude for me every
day since I moved out legit every day
since I moved out it could be small tiny
little things and I'm just like oh now I
get it this is the pain of paying taxes
I get it now oh this is what cleaning
your room is like and your parents not
being there to tell you to do it you
just need to do it because no one else
is going to do it you know just small
little things and it's like yeah totally
when I was a kid and I was leaving with
my parents and my parents were doing
everything for me it's like I didn't
[__] understand it of course I didn't
cuz I never been thrown into that
position but now that I am and now that
I'm a fully functioning adult I can
understand like oh okay my parents were
right what a shock and I think it's
because of that that my respect grew for
them even more so than it was already
yeah but like the tough thing as a
parent I I feel like is that you just
have those [__] years when they're
like between the ages of I'd say 14 and
19 where they're like [__] you I know
the best I know everything cuz I know
that's going to happen cuz I thought
that until I realized in my [__] mid
20s that I'm like [__] I was a [__]
[__] [__] and I was I was a
dumbass I didn't know anything I think
you just got to you got to instill the
values that you you want them to get and
not too much as a teenager you got have
that but you let them go czy and do hit
and on Tik Tok see I see I didn't have
that period when I was in high school I
was I was a suck up to my parents I was
I was like if if if a parents like if
there's teachers pets I was the parents
pet like I was like everything I did I
was like I don't want to disappoint my
mom I don't think I like spoke to my
parents for like 3 years what well not
like in a meaningful way really I think
I was just like no I don't know I don't
know how my parents did did it but like
they just gave me that environment where
I was like oh yeah I can just talk about
anything with my parents well my parents
did I think I was just a little [__] I
think I just didn't want to and I think
that I just need to figure that out
myself did your dad beat
you such a
good what this is like it's like the arm
chest psychologist I know like I like
the color orange did your dad beat you
yeah real real question no the only the
only thing that my dad did to is that
occasionally if we were up too late he
would come in with the slipper and hit
us on the butt with it oh that's that's
Charles play what do you mean what did
you get [__] WrestleMania oh dude I I
got full fist what no that's too much
that's too much but like my dad was
really okay my dad was really I'm not
saying my dad was violent okay what the
[__] full fist yeah but like he I don't
know he was a [__] like shalling monk
with this [__] cuz like he would he
would like throw the fist like either
like on the shoulder or just like you
know
yeah just like like one of those right
but he did it in a way where it didn't
hurt it was just a lot of force right
you know what I mean so like when you
when you when you punch him on the
shoulder like being like stopping a
little [__] like that he would punch it
in a way where it wouldn't like leave
like a Mark or anything like it wouldn't
like hurt immediately but it would push
so bad but but it would but it would
push me back and that force is what
scared me okay for the record I know my
dad watches trash taste dad I realized
you didn't beat me up as a child okay I
know there wasn't any like child
endangerment [__] happening but from
just like that little thing of like
realizing that my dad is like a a
literal force to be reckoned with right
is what instilled that fear in me of
respect and I think that's what kind of
disciplined me knowing that like I don't
want to see my dad be like that to me
because that clearly upsets him and I
don't want to see my parents upset you
know so like he kind of did it in a way
which I think for me obviously cuz I
have a lot of respect for my parents
obviously uh but you know whenever I got
into any bad things then like I would
have that fear you never want to fall
into that fallacy of like it works for
me cuz sometimes sometimes people would
turned out like very well-rounded
individuals in spite of some of the
things that happened in their childhood
and I would say that a lot of the times
um you know this is this is something
that a lot of people figure out is that
a lot of the times you can hold on to
scars for things that you don't even
know you hold on to scars for until you
like grow way older and maybe like talk
to a th therapist or something you're
like wait yeah I would be perpetually
scared about that yeah yeah and and and
you're like wait I I I thought I was a
balanced individual until I started
talking to people and I'm like wait did
I turn into this person in spite of what
happened or because of what happened you
know so you know you never want to fall
into that fallacy no of course and uh
that's kind of like what that's that's a
hard that's the hard thing of what you
have to try and figure out as you grow
older cuz you what you want to do or at
least my life philosophy is you know as
a kid you're like my parents are the
best my parents are super human they're
perfect and then you realize as you grow
older that hey they were just trying to
be the best person they can be and learn
from their parents and when you realize
that you're going to be that same person
you're going to try and take the good
thing from your parents and try to learn
from the mistakes that made as well
that's kind of like the life cycle of
what I think is being a good parent and
being a good child um um because I think
the worst thing you can do is just learn
nothing from your parents and don't try
to improve on them or something I think
is equally bad is that when I've seen so
many people where their parents have
done some kind of [__] up or done
something bad that's [__] them up and
then they kind of like pivot and go 360°
the opposite direction and makes the
completely OPP 360° would be the same
direction sorry
180° 180° in the opposite direction
spins around spins around yeah because
like for me I remember like I remember
the the fear of disappointment was
always greater for me as a person than
the fear of like any kind of like oh I
could get like you know I could get like
a slap or something or like you know oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah to to to me the
threats of like let's say like violence
um not that that really ever happened in
my household but like the like I was
always more scared
uh of disappointing my parents
expectations of me than I ever was like
I I think at some points I'd be like I I
I would prefer the I would prefer the uh
instant gratification of just being like
you know just just just come on come on
come on come on Mom just just just just
give me a slap on the wrist please
please that's that's the instant
gratification please cuz like that's
that's when I knew for example that like
my parents were like actually like
proper mad at me is the moment when they
wouldn't result violence when they would
they would have what I what I like to
call the silent disappointment you know
what I mean like were like the quieter
and more like uh Karma tone that they
speak to me in signify to me immediately
oh I'm actually in like deep deep [__]
right now like there so angry that they
can't even get angry at me yeah my dad
had this uh thing that we called the
murder stair oh yeah cuz there's three
of us uh three three brothers so we we
all had like we all knew and if he gave
you the stare you were done you done it
was like Empress hockey just like it was
like oh you like oh no you knew it was
going to my dad hated that we called he
hated that we called it that but it was
it felt like you about to be murdered it
felt it felt like that my my dad used to
threaten me with uh [__] so D I don't
know if I've talked about this on the
podcast when me and my sister were
really young I'm talking like less than
5 years old whenever we whenever because
it only works I don't think I remember
anything below the age of five okay this
is the one thing I remember uh because
he used to say it all the time whenever
we would like say something that like he
didn't agree with or like we would ask
too much from him my dad would say this
one thing which is don't make me take
you to the
bridge
what wait and that's all he had to say
for us to be like no not the bridge
because I don't know how it came up with
it but like in our dumb less than
5-year-old childhood brains we had
envisioned this like really scary bridge
where like if you cross it you die or
something or like if you cross it
something bad happen and my the most
Joey dad thing i' ever and my dad I
think overheard me and my sister talking
about this we maybe s in like a story
book or something I don't know what it
was maybe The Three Billy Goats gr or
some [__] you know um but like there was
this like Bridge we were like scared in
and I guess my dad over heard him he was
like perfect ammo so now so then every
time we were like Dad can you buy us
like blah blah blah can you take us blah
blah he was just like don't make me take
you to the bridge go to the [__]
Bridge yeah and then we were like I'm
sorry don't don't take us to the bridge
I swear pleas SP us not the bridge your
dad's very uh opportunistic man oh my
dad was smart as [__] with that I'm
using that on my kid that's genius
that's genius the bridge that's genius
because it's such an O it's such an open
threat that doesn't resolve anything
because like it doesn't resort to
anything because there is no bridge but
just saying you're going to go to that
bridge is the threat you need yeah it's
terrifying [__] I still remember some
people call it trauma I I call it good
parenting dad like I'm going to kill you
I'm going to punch you take to the
bridge I'll do all Jesus be a little
[__] oh my God oh my Lord and look look
who it turned into I I became the man
that my dad wished for I I think the
just the one thing that my my parents I
really am glad they did is that they
just showed an interest in most things I
was doing even if they didn't give a
[__] really like but they would always
show interest I think that's why maybe
then I was scared to disappoint them
because I knew they were genuinely
interested and so then if I did do bad
in SCH i' go I'm telling them like I
didn't do good in this I'm sorry and
then they'd be like ah well no food
sorry no I'm kidding no
food uh no I think I think yeah just I'm
really grateful they showed honey get
the ball in chain and it's hard it's
hard cuz like showing interest in I
think I if a kid came to me and was like
man my macaroni art was great I'd be
like [__] okay I can do
better yeah I I don't I don't even know
what the okay I I like I I'm trying to
remember why I was like so
scared of like disappointing my parents
cuz it wasn't like they actually openly
showed any disappointment like if I got
a bad grade in School um you just knew
that they were they weren't proud or
something okay like here's the thing
right I I think this this is like one of
the things I I'm just like realizing now
as a core memory they're like we don't
care they told me we don't care what
grade you get as long as you knew that
you tried the hardest so every time so
every time I came in with a bad that
would work on every kid I don't know why
I don't know why that worked for me
though that that is an Asian parent
method if I've ever heard it my mom used
to say the exact same thing that's the
long con dude that's the long it's the
long con so every time I got a bad grade
in School they would just ask me they
just ask me did you try as hard as you
could have and I would just like [__]
panic and I'm just like I knew I knew I
cuz like I I knew when I didn't try then
I was disappointed in myself and I think
I I think what they like five head
taught me was that they would they
weren't the ones that were disappointed
in me I was the one that was
disappointed in myself for not achieving
my full potential and I'm just like
that's [__] five it's that it's that
question of like we're not mad but are
you
satisfied didn't think so and that's
what started the grind set baby that's
how you get into the grind c yeah um so
like my parents did a lot of things
right I think um they you know some
things I'm I hope to learn from them and
some things I you know you know would
leave in their generation see I think
that method as W though of like that
making you realize whether you're
satisfied with it or whether you're
disappointed in the results that you
made is not only a really good thing to
like teach or instill into kids while
they're still in school but also like
it's just great for like building up
this like self motivation mindset as an
adult you know because like you wake up
in the morning and you're just
constantly on that idea like you know
it's a Ed sword right like you you'll
obviously always have that like hunger
to like strive for better but there's
also that double-edged sword of you're
never going to be satisfied with where
you currently are in life right so it's
it's difficult like teetering on like
whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing some for some people that's a
really good thing like you know for like
people like us for instance who we
obviously without us being motivated to
do it work isn't going to be done money
isn't going to be made yeah but you know
for someone who's working in like an
office job that's not really a mindset
that works